comparison to other people is fantastic
most people just do it wrong you look at
somebody else you see their life you see
what they're doing you see their
business you see their success you see
how old they are is one of the common
question people ask well how old are you
well this because they want to judge
their own progress against yours the
comparison can be great but you have to
use it as a kick forward instead of a
kick down most people will kick
themselves down they realize that you
haven't done much you realize that
you're not where you want to be you
realize all these other people have done
it with maybe less resources than you at
an earlier age than you and you feel
like it's over and you can't do it
that's a kick down it's a comparison
it's a kick down and that's what most
people do and that there's so much
advice out there from people saying
don't compare yourself to others because
when we do it we kick ourselves down
that's the wrong way to do it the
comparison to other people comes from
knowing what's possible and being
inspired to want to go off and do it